hey guys i'm james marshall and welcome
to the swish waterload podcast yes this
episode is proudly brought to you by
swish which is an awesome platform which
gives you the opportunity to get a video
message from one of your favorite sports
stars it's perfect for any occasion
birthdays weddings or even some good
old-fashioned banter with your mates the
prices are very affordable starting from
as little as twenty dollars and on top
of that you can get an extra discount
with the special water lad code for
water led listeners which is of course
what a lad and my favorite part is that
a large portion of the proceeds go
straight to kiwi kids charities there is
so much to love about this platform i'll
leave a link in the description so that
you can just go and click on that to
check it out also you may have heard the
legendary lad tim bateman pop up on a
few episodes lately anyone who's
listened to the tim bateman episode will
know that he's a champion lad and one of
the smartest people that i know and what
he's done with ostudio has been awesome
to watch from afar he's created the
largest well-being and recovery center
in new zealand it's an industry that's
rapidly growing as we realize the
importance to spend time on our mental
and physical health oh studio has seen
huge growth yet they've decided to
expand throughout new zealand and abroad
so there's an opportunity for you to own
your very own o studio honestly if i
could this would be something i'd
definitely be looking into tammy will
guide you through the process and will
help you set up and run your very own o
studio if you're interested head over to
studio.co.nzlad
and i'll also leave a link in the
description so you can just go click on
that also puresport had their muscle and
joint voted the very best in uk and
honestly i am not surprised anyone with
muscle or joint pain should not just put
up with it instead go give this pure
sport muscle and joint bomb a try add a
couple of drops of the oil just before
bed and i can promise you you will
definitely feel the difference it is the
most tested and trusted cbd in the world
with professional athletes all over the
world using it and i do have a very
special discount of 20 off for world led
listeners with the code water lad 20 and
same again i'll leave a link in the
description for you to go and try well
it's awesome to have so many partners
help bring this podcast to you but let's
get to it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh what a lad well i got a message from
someone the other day ask me why i never
get blues lads on which is probably fair
enough but trust me when i say that i'm
going to make it up to you with this one
as i have one of the greatest lads to
ever play for the blues he's also a
northland tanifa legend and definitely
one of the real characters of the game
he is new zealand's favorite redhead it
is the great tom robinson welcome mate
yes no i'm not sure what finlay will
think about that
yeah supposed to actually say one of the
great redheads
it's probably 50 50 split on the nation
yeah
yeah i actually uh this summer i had
someone come up to me and be like finlay
and i was like
all right
and i had a pleasure to be here mate um
i'm a big fan especially of the prank
i think uh
last year we were moving out of our flat
about
three four days of solid cleaning and
and we just had those pranks playing out
and it was gold man got us through it
didn't get the bond back but
[Laughter]
yeah i've always been wanting to get a
few tiny fires on a prank but um they're
hard work
yeah
it's more than we look up there yeah
that's it i think so but anyway mate
since we got so many questions in for
the champion lad yourself i was hoping
to
start this podcast a little bit
differently start with some questions
finish with some questions and get your
journey in the middle but the one that
was probably the most popular was one
from a couple of weekends ago what was
going through your head as bryn gatlin
lined up that penalty oh my [ __ ]
i think i was praying to every single
god i've ever heard of me
no i actually joked that i had a i
actually joked that i had a multi rna
she's 12 and under
um yeah and when he missed that far out
pretty happy man
poor followers
[Laughter]
you definitely look like you found your
religion um that day i'm not sure if
you're religious or not but you were
definitely thanking the heavens yeah
talking to so many of the gods i don't
know which one actually pulls through
for me so
maybe that'll be the journey in the rest
of my life find out which one
what's your gut say which one do you
reckon
i don't know
[Laughter]
start your own religion yeah
a little communal commune up north
pretty much already is up there
yeah they just need a leader and mate
you're the perfect man yeah
legalize marijuana and our economy will
be booming man
oh good start okay next question this
was probably the second most popular
actually all about the locks any secrets
to keeping the lock so luscious and what
sort of shampoo what's your what's your
regime
good question
um
they're all natural you know that's the
approach i go for just get natural
approach a lot of salt water
um a lot of grass
a lot of sweat
um that's pretty much it and then that
takes care of it
that's good that's easy care yeah now
i've actually gone through a bit of
routine brushing once a day really helps
it was a while where i just couldn't
really brush it and then i just rely on
conditioner just to get out all the
knots and
dreads and stuff but um i go for the
natural natural approach have you got
any plans whether you know is it a long
term thing uh
not sure i tell you what it actually
started we were having a game of 500
and
we were like well we got to put
something on it you know
and um well all right whoever losers has
to go to here for six months
and um
i ended up losing
and um and so
i grew it up for six months and my that
six month stage i was like
well truth i can't get any uglier than i
am now like amazing somebody just keep
going i just was mocked like
i don't even know how to describe it and
then i i sort of kept growing it and
then uh it was sort of i always said i
reckon the reason why i made super was
because i had the long hair just
everyone thinks i'm everywhere but it's
just because easy to spot and
i've kept it ever since
increased your work rate yeah
yeah exactly
yeah all these stats came out of nowhere
but uh if i didn't had to do anything
i'd i'd go for a nice sort of
80s sort of
turn now that sort of thing you know
when time's right i'm not sure when the
time is
but no plans at the moment that would
look cold
[Laughter]
oh well good stuff okay next one
um
does the carpet match the drapes this
one came in a couple of times
once for yourself
i just love an excuse to get together
yeah nice the beaming light
follow the light
of the beacon
okay next one does he ever get randoms
to do the tunny fart chant
oh i don't need to find random they just
enough of those
the enough of the fans up north they
just love today
there's this one guy there's like a
group of them
and they just follow us everywhere like
it's
unbelievable like the support those show
is and they're good characters too
there's one guy we call him all um blue
and if you've ever been to an orphan
game he's their old paladin
after about 600 beers deep
and
i remember like a couple of times i've
gone out after the game
and we'll just be walking around town
you know being a pissed and every now
and then you just hear this
and he's still up and he's still going
so
yeah it doesn't seem to um everyone's
pretty happy to do it
well they do have some of the great
supporters they up there in the tony
farland yeah but the unbelievable way
the funniest fans they'll be on tour
this year i'm sure
no doubt okay next one what's the
greatest music video you've produced out
at sea
didn't want to bring it up but um
i'm actually part of a band i'm a pretty
big deal it's uh
999 megabytes because we never get a gig
turns out there's actually more than a
thousand megabytes and a gig but anyway
and um
yeah pretty much
a few years ago
collins actually he um found this yacht
online
and uh we all there's four of us put
money into it
and that we didn't even know how to sail
we've been sailing a handful of times
like decent 24 foot you know sort of
decent size
and um yeah we we got into sailing and
then some reason why we decided to it'd
be funny to do music videos out in the
yacht so
there's a couple floating around on my
instagram
is that something you'd look to do maybe
get into music oh i might i'd love to
but um
i can't seem to save myself just play a
little bit of guitar and live in
harmonica
but like it'd be awesome but you can act
you're good for the good for the videos
how good would it be just have a i'd
love to have a little crew you just go
to
go to a pub and just jam for a little
bit you know a couple of
couple of songs
get booed out yeah and then just off you
go you're taller cheering you'd be
yeah
okay this one's actually on sailing as
well tell us about the first time you
went sailing in your new yacht
bit of a disaster was it
hey
what was it what
it's like i've been sailing maybe
a handful of times but it was all my
mates yard up up north and it was a you
know it was a self-feeling jib and
everything so we got this new yacht and
we had no clue it took us ages how to
work out to put up the main and stuff
and
we've got five of us on board and we
finally get it sailing
and um
i don't know if you know walking very
well but when you drive
north over the harbour bridge and you
look out to the left there's all these
hidden sandbars
so we're we're standing along we're like
keeling over we're thinking oh we've got
this down backward look at us go
we're going that way and everyone else
is coming that way
well this is weird like we're clearly in
a good spot here while they're going
that way
and uh we had that navionics app and
and collins was like let's say there's
land over there but it's clearly not
land like i can see water
and then before you know it just has a
thumb and yes everyone just goes
so after a while we realized we've gone
nowhere so we get we get two of the boys
up on the bow and two on the stern
and collins is on the um
he's just got the outboard and he's on
the tiller
so he we um we're kind of lifting the
lifting the yacht up and just inching
forward inching forward slowly off this
december
and then um we finally get it off but
obviously we're not hanging around for
long so
three of us jump on board quick and then
one one hugh got left behind
i'll never forget like looking back he
just
then i get in the dinghy
and we go
i go pick him up in the dinghy and then
we get back to the yacht
and then we start sailing along again
and then all these boats out there
fishing are just like pointing pointing
behind us we're like what's going on
they're looking to hide us the dinghy's
come off
is that why you've got into um marine
safety ads i see lately
yeah
yeah
just when they see me they're saying
what they want me to do a marine safety
i just we just laughed today
[Laughter]
so yeah
oh absolutely classic love that one okay
a couple more before we get into it but
favorite tree from the northland region
oh no the beautiful cody tree
yeah yeah that's the easiest question i
learned through my life i reckon yeah
fair enough i would just say the wild
ginger plant that everyone those signs
everyone's like destroy wild ginger
that'll come and poke stick in there
underrated that's the most underrated
plant
yeah yeah
okay next one biggest effort you've gone
to to [ __ ] block your flatmates
[Laughter]
pretty much
flatmate he uh he's been out of
christchurch a couple of weeks earlier
and uh he met this bird you know got off
got along with her quite nicely
nothing's happened but he started
chatting away anyway she she flies up to
auckland this one weekend
and um collins and i are like oh this is
going to be great so he's going off to
pick her up from the airport we find out
who she is
and we print off about
30 or 40 photos of it
and uh
we put them all we put them all
like all up in the room and we like
light all these candles and put
photos up here on the line and stuff
and then these ones
obviously we're pranking each other we
bring each other all the time
but we're [ __ ] a message like oh can
you take a joke and he's just like what
the [ __ ] have you done
so anyway he can't tell him and walk
into his room and shoot reactions just
like what the [ __ ] is going on here
she was a she was a good thought about
it so it was um yeah
they're not still together
no no it didn't work out
he's got a piss passing glitter on him
too but i don't know why but
oh
oh geez that is good stuff i love stuff
like that
yeah prank's at its best oh my i've had
some good ones
over the years i think uh
up there
it was perfect you know and um
i come across a bit of lube and i made
it in the bedroom
so i um
take a bit of chili powder
and um
but then just put this chilli
[Music]
like he just sort of
started burning and was like oh what the
what are you like that's weird like what
have i got
and then um
that was nick to the like pick those
he just got the smoke he's just like
all this milk
[Music]
next level
yeah
that's good
stuff oh so good far out
you would be nervous times being your
flatmate
yeah you know and trust me now i don't
know why but
that's a hell of a start to the body i
knew you're a lad but geez
but i am keen to get through your
journey life growing up in kerry kerry
what an amazing spot it is out there
give us the rundown of what your life
was like growing up up there oh man like
looking back now i had the best troll
today grew up on a
organic farm beef and sheep
outside about 10 minutes outside carry
and
we just ran wild i just
always out in the farm riding horses
um having fights sisters from trying
whisper at each other
most of the time end up eating eating it
myself and me and my mate come back
crying
to mum
but um it was cool i had such a good
spot to grow up we were we were so lucky
that to grow up on a farm and then
grandparents had a boat so suddenly we
just been on the water
um out in the bay of islands just weeks
weeks out there and
fishing and swimming with dolphins and
all that sort of good stuff they
had a great childhood hey that is living
yeah what age we're riding horses uh
pretty young
we just we just go right off thinking we
were
lord of the rings characters and
riding around the farm destroying golf
and um yeah parents will just let us go
off and
sort of when i think about it now like
you go off and shoot rabbits you're old
man just give you a 22 and just be like
all right show me you can use it
properly
show them you can use it and then off
you go
just slow down to the back of the farm
i often wonder now like because to get
to the spot you sort of had to look past
one of the paddocks on the main road and
i often think now like cars driving by
seeing this
young little kid with a 22
just walking along but
it's all just the norm up there
yeah but your your old man was a all
black too wasn't he yeah yeah yeah he
was uh he was all black yeah
he went one tour over to
europe
got four
four games for them and plenty i think
it was about 70 year old for the tunnels
yeah
so he loved that i just just
he even now like
now that i'm he's not coaching the teams
that i'm in he just
goes and coaches the local club team
high school to him and yeah and he was
always coaching and i was real lucky
like
anything i really wanted to do
and my parents would
allow it to happen you know so very
fortunate so when did you fall in love
with the game of rugby or was it did you
feel like it was sort of put upon you
yeah dad's like you want to be an all
black
he's dead
give me a thousand burpees
i'm only five years old
[Laughter]
as long as i can remember
i love that i think it's a little photo
of me i'm probably about two years old
and
and dad boots as a young kid so that's
all i ever wanted to do what's your gun
yeah my gun is two years old
but um
yeah we always loved today
and were you good
uh
i was good when i was real young and
then everyone had puberty and me being
ginger didn't let puberty i still don't
know if i've had puberty
and um like for junior staff i was and
then
sort of once i had high school
i didn't really i think i made rolling
mills which was that year seven eight
comp and then after that i don't
didn't really play
footy i think i didn't make down the 14
team then i got called in didn't make
under 16's and made the
android team but
yeah when i was when i finished high
school i couldn't have been about 80
clicks probably saying height as kerry
kerry got much of a rugby program up
there what's their first 15 like
uh
they're getting theater but it's
different up north oh they kind of can't
decide whether to go club rugby or first
something because obviously it's such a
massive region there's a whole bunch of
high schools so we used to play first of
all on the wednesdays
and then we'd play club footy on the
weekends yeah and the club footy was a
stronger comp because like for example
our curriculum team people coming from
obviously kyrie carrier people coming
from ohio or kaikohe or
ohio or places like that now and now i
think it's about it's a better bit when
we played when i was playing i think
an awkward grammar second 15 came up and
put about 50 points on us or something
yeah
so what was your pathway from school
once you left school what you decided to
do yeah
uh my pathway is a little bit
different to a lot of people so i um
obviously finished high school about
80 clicks
in the same height that i am now so i
was so there was sort of a rough
northland academy
my last year of school but it wasn't
i don't know it's nothing like it is now
so
went down to uni and didn't have any
offers or anything like that and
just went into halls down there and i
think i actually applied for a what they
call the john drake rugby scholarship
at um auckland varsity and i missed out
on that but
i was just like oh well it's a club so
went down to uni in auckland um joined
the club there
and then first year like just i don't
know i sort of knew the size that i was
that i probably wasn't gonna
make
npc until i was about 21 so that first
year uni i just like
had a good time and
and just really like just you know
played buddy for fun and enjoyed the
nights afterwards more more than the
actual footy
um side of things and then got to the
secondary uni that sort of first year
setting
and i was like oh
you know all right i'm gonna if i want
to make this i always want to pay for
the tummies i'm gonna make the tunnels
and i'm probably gonna have to
get to about
you know put on some decent decent size
get up to about 108.
and so obviously wasn't
in an academy or anything like that so
flatmate and i
we um just looked up google how much
protein do
the bodybuilders eat
and i think it was like
it was like 200 grams of protein so i
was like all right sweet i'll divide
that by six
and um
you know it's roughly like over 30 or
grams a meal so
i hope that's the right mess
and um
and so i was alright so i started just
having these six meals a day and just
counting the protein
and then i
so i was just waking up having smoothie
then
when i was walking around uni i was
walking around with
tuna rice
rice
mint
pasta
three containers
and then i was like well obviously i
need to
start doing some gym work
to put on this the size so we looked we
heard this sort of thumbs article about
um hugh jackman how he got real like
jacked with that wolverine and put on
another side yeah
so i was all right so we looked up the
gym program we just started pumping that
out at the uni gym
and then
at the second
year of uni and
um and then made prem's team that that
you have ashley prims and then we won
the final and then after the final i got
called into the auckland
npc squad that's right and it was sort
of pretty crazy because the previous
year like i hadn't even made um
auckland 20s or 21s or whatever it was
and it was also real bizarre because
growing up up north like you you hate
auckland rugby yeah like for passion
because you always just get pumped
so i was like and and the first
preseason game was against the tunnels
and i was just like oh my gosh i just i
was just like obviously i was stoked to
be there but
i just felt so strange i used to have my
little north on top on
underneath
on the way up to the game
and then
obviously played that pre-season game
and then the northern coach got in touch
and was like yeah we're keen to find you
for next year and
then yeah got signed the next year and
i was on a i was on a contract they
wanted me to go up north and i was like
oh look um
i i enjoy it down here in the in the
city yeah like i'm young and i'm at uni
so they'll all right well you can do
your first semester down there and then
go back up north once you finish and
play the last few rounds of club footy
and
and then playing pc
and then um ended up doing acl actually
that year in club footy so never played
that year and my contract was
conditional and medical too
you don't really care about many side of
things you know
just had to
drink a few more dark horses rather than
you know a nicer drop but
i prefer it anyway
and how was it to deal with that injury
you've had a few injuries in your career
as well and how were you handling that
um it was pretty good at the time though
like my goal was to make npc by the time
i was 21 and
um oh he was still 20 at the time or
something so
i just i was pretty good about it
and just sort of yeah got on with it
pretty much
i don't know i just had that mentality
still young got plenty of time
and then um
then rehabbed that then
came back
played the first mpt season
for northland then got
pulled into the blues as a replacement
player
got when i was attends in brisbane
with the blues and then did my other acl
over there ah
i think that that one had a little more
because i was just sort of
just had that foot in the door you know
what i mean it's a super rugby and
that's it like playing nbc is awesome
but obviously the dream is just to play
footy
all year round you know full time so
and then i actually got got misdiagnosed
and it wasn't until about six weeks six
weeks later
but i found out it was the acl and then
it was like two months before empties
painting started so
i was like oh you can have it up now
try and rehab it so try to rehab it for
a bit and because some people can play
without acls and
actually got was back pretty much
doing everything back 100 and then just
one training just sort of felt it get
away a bit and
that was sort of it really and then
had the op and then yeah nine twelve
months later back with the pennies and
then
2019 the first year got picked up there
following the end to the blues and
speaking about the tunnies what what's
it like up there playing for the tony
far what their environment always looks
like it's a real fun environment to be
in
it is man like
uh it's the most enjoyable environment
that uh i mean like the amount of
characters up there is
it's unbelievable way like just such
good value the conversations the chat
that happens there
i mean obviously
probably need to get our balance a
little bit better in terms of
the professionalism side of things
results
haven't been great but um mate every
year i say it it's the year the tony and
2022 is the year of the tommy wouldn't
surprise me actually and it's one big
comp this year too you're going to take
out the whole com
yeah
my yeah i'm not too sure how i feel
about that actually
[Laughter]
but
i'll i'll be feeling good when we take
out the whole comb
old buddy
get one win and then try to change the
whole bloody comp
meanwhile plenty of won one game
and then going into the blues
environment how was that was that just a
whole new level of professionalism for
you yeah
yeah it was it was pretty cool though
like the tunnels and blues
was the childhood dream who i wanted to
play for and then just to be doing it
like full full time
full-time footy and yeah it was it was
awesome i i learned a lot in that this
year that's for sure i think i learned
to i learned a lot around
the importance of like getting away from
footy i think like for me
like being in the city like i learned
like i needed to get out
get out of the city and get into fresh
air i guess it was sort of the older you
get the sort of
you know when you drive up north and
then you finish school all you want to
do is just go to the big city you know
in a couple years after few years in the
big city you're like wow you actually
really appreciate how
how beautiful it is up there and how
good it is for you so that's sort of
where i
like bought the van and things like that
so if you've got a week off now or
anything i can just i can just get away
and hit
yeah everywhere in the surface pretty
much so you've got a van that you live
in pretty much can live in uh
yeah yeah that's all self-contained so
it's got a
little kitchen in the back and a
mattress and she's uh susie l five star
wagon she's about
she's in 1984
so she's um
she's saying some things that's for sure
she's great value do you rent her out on
airbnb or anything
no no no
no i think
she's broken down a couple of times so
she keeps me on edge so
i don't think i'd i'd want to put some
poor
german tourists through that
yeah fair enough so you you sort of went
into that blues environment when they
were struggling results weren't going
that well
but then what you've been through in the
last three years has been a real shift
by the looks from the outside in
how's that environment changed and
what's it been like
yeah i think
there has been a big change in the
coaches that we've had over the last few
years have been a massive part of that
and it's a real
enjoyable environment to be in
but it's not like the tunnels where
there's still that real
professional edge
and growth mindset that they've really
driven to and i think that's sort of
like they've picked good the buggers and
there's a lot of good characters in the
team and
but then there's also that mindset of
really wanting to to grow as a as a
player so yeah i think that sort of been
the biggest change around
and your game personally has gone from
strength to strength every year um ended
up captaining the side last year to
victory how did you feel about being
named captain of the auckland
oh yeah
well at the time i think i could have
been on the bench for
the first sort of three or four games
and i had like i thought a couple of
good impacts you know
and i was sort of wondering going into
the
meeting on the tuesday with her name the
team and i was sort of wondering that i
was going to be starting or not this
week and then uh ringy comes up to me oh
how do you feel about being kept and i
was like
yeah yeah yeah
but i was still kind of like enemy told
i'm starting you know so i'm like kind
of just
he's oh you're starting to by the way oh
sweet
and then um
it was like a pretty easy transition
because we still had patty there in the
background and he was helping out a lot
and
um
my role didn't was sure just
um with the other leaders was just sort
of that game sort of management and and
the game days sort of in that those
moments and stuff and we had a real
bunch of good leaders too so
but um
i didn't realize how bad daddy's injury
was and so
i thought it was only going to be for
the week and so
every time i get an interview
the uh
the boys always give me a give me a word
that i gotta i gotta get in there like
put an interview
and
you know all right if you're getting the
speech you've got to do as many like
you've just got to do as many cliches as
you can
and i just thought i was like well i've
only got one wiggle so i just got to go
through it so yeah that was the
afternoon speaker i just
yeah i don't know what i thought i said
in the end i just tried to get as many
cliches in there as possible and then
and then it turns out that he was
actually injured for a while so i had to
pack it up for the next one for the next
week and
media manager just like maybe just sort
of rain in a little bit before you go
i always wondered what the story was
behind that interview
yeah yeah that was like give it many
cliches again do they still do it are
you still doing those
in your interviews i'd love to
know what word you've got pre-interview
one day yeah
yeah yeah no we always um
we always uh they always give me one
word i haven't got one for this podcast
i guess
the short ones are the difficult ones
you know the short interviews
um
but it's uh yeah
that's good i had one on i was on seven
sharp and
i had to get
tortoise
turtle
and they were asking him about his old
man
and then after about my old man i said
oh he's
he's uh he's not as fast as a cab's old
man but he's no he's not taught us
either
no turtle he's no turtle either or
something
so have you have you had much feedback
from up top obviously yeah captain of
blues you've been playing some really
good footy did you get any feedback from
the all blacks especially last year when
um i know your name was
whispered around as being a bolter and
things like that and i remember watching
the footage of you and finlay at the bar
sinking pints and watching the
announcement and must have been a bit of
a bittersweet feeling for you i guess
seeing your good mate make the all
blacks but um inside probably a little
bit gutted that your name wasn't read
out as well
yeah
i don't know i guess
no i haven't no i haven't had any sort
of communication or anything but i don't
think i think it's quite common i don't
think a lot of people do but
i guess sort of my mindset was that if i
was going to make it like i'd want to be
in that um my form was so good that
there was no i had no choice you know
what i mean yeah yeah so i think like
like last year like god we've got a chat
going around you know i didn't actually
expect it to be fair it was until
afterwards that a whole lot of people
messaged me
because saying oh i had luck
but yeah we were just we were at the pub
obviously a couple of days after we
we took that um trans-tasman compound
and
it was like what i don't know what that
was but you know
oh we're just hanging around the flat
team sorry found that all right we'll go
we'll go get a feed at the pub
and uh we'll just have one there all
right all right we'll have one there
right
and then you know it'll start so i mean
um
we're like all right then someone's
alright any of the boys here get named
in all blacks then we're sending it
and then um
and my name got read out
so everyone was just like oh here we go
like
oh yeah here we go so you know that was
good time it was cool man awesome it was
real cool to be there exactly and finley
doesn't take too much of an arm twist to
get on the person surely
no
yeah he was sort of kind of
watching
you know young around for a bit
and speaking about your um blues uh when
you won the trans tasman what was that
like what was it like after that whistle
uh the lead up to that week obviously
the blues hadn't won it for a long long
time and to win that comp that year must
have been pretty special yeah it was it
was special i think um
a lot of us
like at the time it was it was awesome
the mindset now sort of like
it's not really the real deal you know
what i mean like unless you're beating
all those new zealand teams you know
that doesn't feel like the real title
but
it was cool for our region it was cool
for us to set a goal and then
achieve it you know
and see everyone work so hard towards
that goal
and then i think like the supporters
like for them what they've gone through
like over the last 17 years or longer
probably you know yeah
um
to see what sort of joy it brought to
the
not only just the city but the region
itself was cool and what sort of shape
do you see the site in this year um yeah
i expect pretty high
where we give 100
out there to win it to win the
real
um the real title yeah um
i think yeah obviously
that week against the cain's was pretty
disappointing um how he finished
um
especially how he sort of touched on how
how teams perceive us
and i think a lot of people perceive us
as sort of 60 70 minute team you know
they'll be strong for that and if you
can stay in the fight they'll
they'll go nothing so it was a shame
that happened but
i think the footy that we played against
the hurricane for that
first bit was a lot of people said some
of the best buddies i've seen them lose
play
um
yeah
i've got yeah pretty high expectations
of what we've achieved
yeah and how do you see the quarter
finals changing the layout of the season
obviously you're probably going to be
making the quarterfinals i think most
new zealand teams will to be fair and
then you'll be having these one-off
games where you have to
pretty much beat everyone to win the com
yeah
it's a strange old sort of setup but um
yeah it's kind of interesting how it
plays out like obviously
you've got eight teams and
and it's quite a lot you know like
but in that quarter final it doesn't
matter
what form you've been in or
whether you're qualified eighth or first
you know going up to anyone so yeah yeah
it's going to be pretty full-on
finish the condo for sure pretty much
playing three finals yeah three finals
i'm guessing
the way their comp structured new
zealand teams will probably end up
playing new zealand teams with a first
and an eighth and a just the way the
aussie teams play each other more
so you might be playing the highlanders
in the first quarter final then you
might have to play the hurricanes of the
chiefs and then potentially the
crusaders so yeah i mean it's going to
be an intense finish to a season a yeah
yeah
and what are your plans going forward
mate have you how long you signed with
new zealand rugby union signed with the
blues the tonys i'd imagine you're a
tiny far for life but
um probably got ambitions to get
overseas at some point
upgrade um susie or whatever the van is
yeah
yeah no
someone got the season and then one more
and then um
i think that'll be five every five
seasons are super ugly yeah i think by
then i'll i'll feel like
i would have given it you know a real
good crack obviously to
see what i can achieve here and and i
think i'll be pretty happy to
to bend to where i am
um but i think i'll be sort of looking
looking to go overseas again yeah
anywhere in particular that really
stands out for you japan europe um
america anything yeah
whatever the money comes
yeah that's what i can get sushi after
last week
[Laughter]
oh um i love the footy lifestyle but
one thing i do miss is being able to
travel and not have to worry about
training and footy you know
and so at the moment we get like a month
off between
nbc and super and you can go you can go
and travel and stuff but you got to be
near a gym you've got to be near a footy
feel
and stuff so
i think the length of japanese season
attracts me because i'd love to just
have a couple of months off where i can
just
you know go away for one month and just
really
travel and get that experience of
traveling and then
didn't have that sort of second month to
to get into good nick and stuff so
the length of the season there
definitely attracts me
um but then you know the european
lifestyle like that would be awesome to
experience that but i think just the
length of this season you know it's just
so long and yeah i love going between
blues and northern i could go i come
down here and it's like yeah i'm really
looking forward to like obviously you've
been in northland for a few months and
you're really on the social aspect of
the city and
going and then after seven months i'm
like all right i need i need some fresh
air i need to get out of the city and
head up north and then i head up there
and then it's cool going between the two
and and different environments and
facilities and then i think just being
stuck on one team for
for that whole year obviously you get
weeks off in between the software
different grind yeah fair enough and
you've also got a very hissing business
that you've just launched zinkel swim
what you're wearing the top looks
unbelievable i'm surprised you're not
wearing the zinc to be fair but
i see you wearing it all the time night
games games doesn't matter one of the
great products yeah i probably should be
i'm under a
roof here but i'm still probably getting
burned for it
um but yeah it's um it's been a cool
adventure i'm doing it with um good
night big six josh could you and pretty
much the idea came about well over a
year from last preseason
we were just getting so sunburned like
because the sunblock was just sweating
off yeah
and uh well i will
try some zinc and um we're trying to
drink and then you know we'd be quite
cool to have you know like a blue zinc
and some colorful things we'd like to
think of ourselves as some colorful
characters yeah and then there was no
natural colored zinc on the market
um so we're sort of quite yeah we're
really keen to wear some natural stuff
and
and then that's how the idea came about
and then
yeah
that's how it started then we finally
launched a couple weeks ago but um
it took a while to get the
recipe and the color right back and
forth trying different samples
drawing the different colors and
pigments and
and then eventually we got it right and
then we had to send it off to sydney to
get spf tested
and then
um because of code over there that was
shut down for about three months
so then uh we couldn't get spf tested so
that's why we're um launching zinc at
the end of summer
[Laughter]
marketing 101
but how's the launch going yeah it's
been it's been really good um we're
lucky to have i guess some like know
enough people high-profile people i
guess
um that really have lent off a hand and
um like what sounds like bodhi he's been
massive for us yeah um getting us in
touch with different people and
and um so really made the most of that
and so we've got our website up and
running single swim or you can buy it
and then now
we're just looking to get to really sort
of expand into retail pretty much
so yeah any surf shops out there or
or stores like that we're just looking
to
get into love it and it's sustainable
and it looks high quality stuff yeah
it's all natural ingredients it's good
for you and give your body and um all
our packaging is all environmentally
friendly and
um we're sort of we're big on that and
um
and then yeah like the color aspect you
know like it's just another chance to
express yourself really and are you
going to play in it at any point yeah
yeah yeah if it's if it's a day game
i'll play it i played last weekend oh
you hit someone last night yeah at the
start that when you get into a bit of
contact like it stays on it's crazy how
long it stays on but when you're getting
into contact and wiping your face on
other people
it isn't that it comes off after a while
but
yeah any day games i'll
wear it on and you just go under the
eyes is it or do you sort of cover the
whole face i go i go full face because
it doesn't it doesn't run so you can put
it above the eyes it doesn't run into
your eyes and
um it doesn't fall through the natural
stuff so it doesn't hurt or affect your
eyes so i got a full face but um as soon
as the main area is there the nose and
yeah under the eyes mate what a product
well if i'm out surfing i'll cover
myself and so it's waterproof as well
yeah yeah yeah so i could go surfing for
hours and
come out and it's all still on and
working so
yeah it's um it's and it's it's not it's
quite easily spreadable too like
some of those things you buy it's like
rock hard and you can't even spread it
so
the stuff you're able to spread what a
product you should set up some
infomercials on the tv you're selling
this so well
wait there's more
you call now
we'll chuck in a free ginger
come around your house
so what's your involvement with the
business now though are you what are you
actually doing now um yeah we're pretty
much both with billy and i are running
it we're real lucky
his uh partner is into graphic design
and stuff so she's helping us out a lot
but yeah we do all the i'm reaching out
to retail people at the moment um and
then
all the orders that come from online um
goodies packaging them up and
and sending them out and
stuff so yeah we're running the whole
thing nice we've got a manufacturer and
an auckland that manufactures it so
um yeah it's all go but it's cool though
like you have a lot of spare time and
footy and
now i just sort of in your spare time
just sort of
chipping away at that but it's your own
sort of
you know your own business so you're
quite happy too yeah 100 it's so cool to
see i love seeing players jump out and
do stuff like that and if you are in a
retail business or you do have retail
space get in touch with big tom robinson
because you need to be selling some zinc
or swim this stuff is some of the best
thing on the market no doubt yeah sure
isn't that yeah 100 get in touch and um
and uh yeah i would love to see our
products and lots of retail stores over
the country let's get it done but as
always we have got the rest of these
questions to finish off we started off
with some of the some of the greats that
we've got plenty more to finish the
first question this one's from swish the
great sponsor of the waterlab podcast
they want to know if you could get a
video call from any celebrity or anyone
in the world who would it be and why
good question
um
paul tito
why he's the greatest celebrity
yeah it's just a it's just such an
argument for us gingers
he was the first he paved the way for us
was he actually like a role model for
you growing up uh
i don't know a role model but i
definitely ripped them you know
it was it was cool you know just to see
something like like that but
um
it's a tough question actually okay next
one favorite northern hero growing up oh
favorite norfolk era growing up uh
probably it was probably renee ranger
right
legend it would be the bigger
when i was a young kid
yeah he's the one that he's the man
you'd say as you're running around the
backyard yeah and then you got to play
with him obviously and then i met him
and he's terrible
no no no
he's
he's a top he's a top lad
got a lot of time for him
actually got a question about him too
what's your best renai ranger story um
i don't know if that's the best story
but i just remember
as a young kid like rocking up
before a blues game they were playing
out north preseason
and just seeing them and attracted smoke
and dark
very very gay
um that's probably a memory that sticks
with me
i think
he's a bit of a freak athlete that's for
sure considering what he does
yeah he's a base though okay next one
tell the yarn about stealing the vodka
on waiheke finlay one of the greats
oh
and that wasn't actually
me so we sailed across the waikiki on
the yacht again
and um we
we wrote ashore you know we had a few
that's for sure
and
we weren't as sure to um
cook dinner and we forgot the pan at the
yachts we're like instead of going all
the way back we'll just pop up look at
this little party going on and asked um
we could borrow pam and i said ah sorry
but there's a barbecue right next door
have a barbecue so we jumped on that and
then we were going back to yacht and
they invited us up
for a beer so we went up there and had a
beer and had a yarn to them
and then um
one of uh we were leaving and one of the
boys in the yacht decided to
take
the half wall of vodka
what's that and we look back and we see
we might just put this bottle down
and
then jesus walks off and then we look
back and there's just this
mob of people just chasing us
so we're like holy heck like so we we
ran off it was a decent run like
we were puffing
yeah
all right well i'll go back and
see if i can kind of explain what's
happened and calm the situation down so
i'm sort of walking back
with my hands in the air like like
apologizing saying sorry like i was like
study idiot runner up
there's one guy just running with a
[ __ ] baseball bat and then this other
dude just running with his hand cocked
like this and i'm like holy heck like
we've got to get out of here so we can
turn around
we keep running down the and there was a
it was a big man too like i got to give
him credit he had some
he had a decent pair of lungs on him
and then we'll all right we'll all right
we gotta we gotta get back um
to the dinghy but we were down the beach
and
then like we were here the batch was
here and our thingy and the outboard was
on the other side so we're like oh
crikey we're gonna have to sneak past
that
blind batch like
and there were big street lamps on the
on the beach so we were like commandoing
through the water like on the edge of
the
each of the thing and
and then we see like a lot of people
walking along so we rush up to the trees
and we're hiding and then there's this
argentinian dude that
was just sleeping there and we
accidentally stand on him and and he
just stands oh no no no we're like shut
up
our way down the beach and then we see
this guy
go and take our outboard
and our oars and we're like oh roof and
then that stage cops showed up and we
explained to them what happened and
mate got a warning and
um we got the we got the awesome
and the outboard back jeez thank god for
the police eh
yeah i know i know
that's a good one i knew finlay would
have a good yarn there yeah
okay the next one we got about two or
three times
um very popular man with the ladies by
the looks ask him if you'll marry me
twice so um obviously you do have a big
following with women do you get that
quite often at games and stuff post
games in town yeah nice
probably some probably one of the 30s or
something between
the demanding it was a fake yeah
probably
uh i'm not oil painting that's for sure
mate
right but the women love it the women
love it
okay next one have you improved your
jacklin skills in detail jackling
skills ah wow that's a terrible
jacqueline three sphere always seem to
get blown out of the way but um we're
just let's loosens up the training and
we'll just usually um
have different drills and stuff set up
so you can kind of have one guy on their
knees and you kind of come along and
scroll them to the ground and just get
on the ball then you get another mate
with a pad to come and try and hit you
off the ball you know make sure you're
solid or pull you forward making sure
that you're holding your weight and
stuff
yeah plenty of drills for jacqueline oh
what a coach love that
okay next one would you rather be a
marine gynecologist or a westpac
helicopter pilot
oh this is good stuff
so when i was a
young kid at varsity and playing first
year prem some of
the older boys funny actually is now
with curt and
marcel and
julie lay and all those boys that are in
the
in the blues now which is actually real
cool we they used to go up the pawn to
me so they took me under my wings
you know or a little yankee ginger and
we got the pawn to me and you start
chatting away to different people and
you sort of soon realize when you told
someone that you were studying at uni
and you were 19 years old no one was
really interested in you
so i started telling people that i was a
um
respectful helicopter
and then and then now sort of like that
you're a 45
it's just boring just telling people
you're a footy player so i i like to
just
you know spark something else up and
i told
i had a mate that said yeah
yeah um
i was telling someone that i was a
marine gynecologist
so i was like oh
oh this will be um
this would be great so we're off to a
swat party and there's a bunch of people
about three or four people when they ask
what to do
and they're like um
i'm like oh i'm a marine gynecologist
and they're like
they sort of look at me
and
they're like what do you mean and i just
go off on the spear about what i do
radar and then they're just like we
don't believe you and then i'm like so
i'm like you yeah i'm like you guys
don't believe me that i'm i'm a marine
gynecologist and he's like
yeah tom they're all um doctors surgeons
but can you actually fly a helicopter
that question came in a few times too
no
no no i can't i wish it'd be pretty cool
chinese whispers from your varsity days
yeah pretty much i promise i came
playing with everyone eventually
oh classic okay last question
best piece of advice tom robinson has
for what led listeners
love finishing on something
inspirational
good question
remember at the end of the day
it's night
oh wow
an inspirational joke
no it's good
matt that's sort of my mind when i've
gone through those injuries it's like it
um always can be worse you know yeah
whatever you're going for it always
could be worse and make the most of make
the most of good luck and make the best
of bad luck however it goes wow geez so
yeah i think it sort of got me for a lot
of things thinking it always could be
worse
and sort of if you waste time dwelling
on on what you're going through you're
just sort of prolonging that process
like this
hey
there is that is so good that is
probably one of my favorites no [ __ ]
that is quality and totally agree mate
things could always be worse like
there's always people in worse
situations than us and as a professional
player with an injury
um it might seem bad at the time but
when you take a step backwards eh it's
really nothing at the end of the day
with what some people are going through
yeah people come up to me like oh i feel
so sorry for you around i'm like
that sucks but man i'm getting paid to
turn up and rehab and go to the gym
you know
like people have to do this and work
proper people have to work proper jobs
and then go do rehab in their own time
and pay for a gym so
yeah love that what a way to finish one
of the great podcasts i knew you were a
lad i'd only heard good things and you
have not disappointed one of the greats
it's been awesome having you on good
luck with the season um good luck with
the blues and hopefully we do see you in
that black jersey sooner rather than
later but really appreciate you coming
on the podcast mate cheers man
appreciate it love your work keep it up
likewise
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]